サッバパパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ サチッッタパリオダパナン エタングブッダナサーサナン
では よろしくお願いします
九十八番 九十八番目の偈にも長いストーリーがついてますけど
そういうテキストとかお持ちの方々はストーリーを読んでみてください
ガーメーワヤディワランニェ ニンネーワヤディワタレ ヤッタアラハントーヴィーラランティ タンブーミンラーマネイヤカン という偈なんです
この偈にはそんなに説明するところはないと思いますけど
ガーメーワというのは
村ということですね ヤディはアランニェ
アランニェっていうのは森ですね
山ですね 日本的に言えば
ニンネーっていうのは盆地
タレっていうのは平らなところ
まとめて言えばどこでもって意味なんです
別にその言葉一つ一つ説明する必要はないんです
村であろうが森で山であろうか
盆地であろうか 平らなところであろうが
どこでもって意味なんですね
どこでもって意味なんです
ヤッタアラハントーヴィーラランティ
アラハントーっていうのは覚ったアラカンですね
覚者ですね 覚った人が生活しているならばどこでもいいんです
どこでもアラカンの方がいるならば
タングブーミンラーマネイヤカン
その場所がとてもラーマネイヤカンって何でしたっけ
美しいというか 気に入るとかね
とても気に入られる清らかな美しい場所であると
心喜ばれる場所であるということですね
で その場所楽しいですということですね
で あのパーリ語の場合は
この単語の間でいっぱい色々単語入りますから
皆さんは混乱するかもしれませんだけどね
だから私は言った単語だけ線引いて覚えておけばガーメー
で それからアランニェなんですね
ヤディワっていうのはこの間に入る単語なんですね
ニンネーっていうのは盆地
で またワとヤディとワとまた三つ入ってやりまして
それからタレ 平らなところ
それはどういう風に訳すればという解説すれば
はい ここであの注釈書ではこういう意味になってますね
で 一般の人々がああ この場所はちょっと気に入らないとかね
こちらはちょっと大騒ぎしているんだからとかね
もう場所に文句を言うんですね
普通の人々は 阿羅漢の方々は場所に文句言わないんです
どこにいてもすごい心穏やかで生活するんだと
ああ とてもいい場所だと
阿羅漢たちはどこに行ったっても言うことなんです
なんていいところでしょうかと
すごく穏やかな気分でいられるんでしょうと
もう街のど真ん中にいるはめになっても同じこと言うんです
なんていいところでしょうかと
そこで険しい山の中に生活することになっても
なんていいところですかと
では 人が混雑している村のど真ん中に住むはめになっても
また同じこと言うんです
だから場所に文句言わないというポイントなんですね
はい そこで我々一般人との差がよくわかるでしょう
で 私たちはやっぱり場所が気になるんですね
で 修行しやすい場所もあるし
修行できない場所もあるし
まあ混乱する場所もあるし
気持ちいい場所もあるし
気持ち悪い場所もあるし
まあ大変ですね 一般的には人間というのは
時々ね まあこういうところはあまり人もなくて
もう近いところにコンビニもなくて困ったな
大変厳しい場所だなとかね
まあ言ったりもするし
で どんな差ですかね この場所に文句言う私たちとどんな場所にも何の文句も言わない阿羅漢たちの差は何ですかね
阿羅漢たちが昔はね あの
あの遺体捨て場もありましたからね
もうぞっとする場所でしょ
人が死んじゃったらそのまま運んで捨てて帰って帰るんだから
もう誰も行くところじゃないんですね
それで周りがもう狼やら
特にあの狐ですね で来て
もう死んだ死体を食べたりするんだから
インドでは昔からもうこの犬がいてね
いまだにインド人は犬飼わないんです
全部野生の野良犬なんです
あの飼って放した犬は一人もないんです
自然に野良で生活した犬たちなんです
昔から それでインドにしかないんです
他の国々になると やっぱり犬を飼っているんですね
だから皆さんもインド巡礼すると結構犬は見たことあるでしょ
あれは人間には一度でも飼ったことがない
野生で生まれて野生で大きくなった犬たちなんです
それでそれ言ったのは
やっぱりこの遺体捨て場っていうのは
結構犬たちが来て遺体を食べたりする
そういうところで一晩泊まることになっても
阿羅漢たちにこの場所はちょっと危ないんじゃないんですかと
いえ こんな穏やかな場所はないんでしょう
なんて綺麗な場所ですか
随分気持ちよくいられますよ
と言うんですね それが何なのかと
すごいシンプルなポイントなんです
私たちは心が弱くて誘惑されるんですよ
それだけなんです 自分が自立してないんです
偉そうに私が私が俺がとか言うんだけど
ちょっと環境変わっただけで心が変わってるんですね
何が私がですかね 聞きたくなるんです
随分自我張ってるくせに
事実はまるっきり正反対なんです
商店街に行ったらもう気分が変わっている
デパートで行ったらもう気分気分が変わっている
電車に乗ったらもう気分が変わっている
だから何なのかと 自分という存在がね
そこをちょっとチェックしてください
自分というしっかりした
安立したね 安定した自分がいるのかいと
全くもなくて いつでも誘惑されっぱなしで
何に誘惑されるかわからないでしょ
だから自分というのはもう全然安心できないんです
自我を張っているんだけど
全く安心できないんですね
ちょっと環境が変わっただけでもう変わっているんだから
ですから そこら辺なんですね
言いたいポイントっていうのは
そんなに見るものに 聞くものによって
心はもう誘惑されない
揺らがない 安定しているんですね
だから 阿羅漢になった人は動揺させるということは不可能
他の経典でお釈迦様が言うのは
もうすごい石 石でできている石山であったら
でっかい石山ありますね
風が吹いてもね 台風が来てもね
全く動じないでしょうにと
そのように阿羅漢に達した人の心が何にも動じませんと
完全安全な境地に達しているんですね
そういうことで そこで阿羅漢の心の一つの特色が勉強できると思います
シンプルでしょう 意味は
分かりやすいと思います
だから 私たちにはものすごい問題多いんでしょうに
いくら頑張っても解決できないんですね
何か一つ解決すると もう新しい何か
気に入ってるアパート見つかると日が当たらないというんですね
日が当たるアパート見つかると狭すぎというんです
それで日が当たって狭くもないアパート見つけたら
スーパーに遠いんだと
あるいは駅に遠いんだと
15分歩かなくちゃいけないと
なんとか言うでしょうに
だから生まれた時からもう学校に文句言うわね
結婚したら相手に文句言うわ
もうキリがないんですね
子供が生まれてきたら子供に文句を
ということで 一般人の人生っていうのはもう解決できん
もう いつでも何か何か何か何かトラブルがあるんですね
それで面白いことに この問題さえなければ私が幸せだというでしょ
よく言うこと うちの子は真面目に勉強するならば
もう他何とも私に文句はないんだよと
それさえやれば私は幸せだと言ってますけど
本当にそうなのかと それってありえないんです
これさえ 1個だけ問題取り上げちゃってね
ではなくて 我々は無数のことにいつでももう文句言ってるんですね
これが一般の人間の人生なんです
心にはひとかけらも安らぎがないんです
だから必死で走り回ってますよ
友達を探すは あの友達は嫌
知り合いは この知り合いは
あの人と付き合いたいとかね
場所を探して走り回るは
食べ物を探して走り回るは
あの店でとにかくあの店のラーメン
もう 3時間待ってでも食いたいとかね
そういう風な もう落ち着きのない人生は一般人が送っているんですね
それで阿羅漢になってきたら
全くもう信じられない落ち着きがあるんです
で そこはもうすぐだいたい一般人も一般人はね
人が悟っているかないかとかね
知りたがるんだけど 知りたければ
まあこういうこの阿羅漢章ですけどね
この中でなんとなくお釈迦様が説かれてるんですね
あなた方にはこの心の状況はわかりませんけど
しかしこんなものやと
だから 人もね 緊張しないんですね
人も緊張しないし 場所に文句言わないしね
環境に文句言わないし
それは真理に達しているんだからできているんですけど
真理っていうのは全て無常でね
情報が眼耳鼻舌身に触れるたびに心が変化していく
流れていくんだということはよく知っていて
それによって欲が生まれたり
怒りが生まれたり 恐怖感が生まれたり
何か見ると恐怖感が生まれる
何か見ると欲が生まれてくる
何か見ると緊張してしまうという心が
ただ目から入る情報によって激しくかき回されている
そんなものは無常の流れを観察しながらいるだけで
心に貪瞋痴がないんだから
激しくかき回すことも何もないんです
無常になりきっているんで
無常になりきると自我もなくて
何か自分という気持ちもないんですね
自分がいるという気持ちもなくなっちゃうと
場所に文句を言う必要ないでしょう
だから無常になりきっているんですね
そういう精神的な状態だけなんですね
体見て この人阿羅漢だということは言うことは全くできませんし
一般の人にはもういくら頑張ってもわからないと思いますよ
それで あの人されているのかと調べる人に限って心が性格悪いんですね
我が強くて 自分のことをすごい偉そうに考えている人々だから
仏縁がなくなっているんですね
それで自我がなくて謙虚で心軽らかにしたいという修行をしたいという人々には
一応何となくわかるようにはしますけどね
教育的にはね 教育的でないとそれも言わない
それはアドバイスとして
実はね こういうことだよとかね
それ以外はもうバレるようにはしません
で 自分が阿羅漢であるということは言う必要もなくなっているんですね
自分ということもなくなっているんだからね
だから一般的には探さない方がいいんです
どうしても俺が知りたいと言ったら
その人その時点でもう仏縁がなくなっています
知りません だから阿羅漢たちをいっぱい悟った人々いっぱい世間に出して
そこはテレビコマーシャルで流して
もう三千百三十人も阿羅漢たちがいるんだとか言って
そういう宗教宣伝しませんからね
そもそも宗教でもないし
人の心の問題を直してあげると
それで話が終わっていますからね
あんたは直してほしくないんだったら
まあどうぞということでするだけでね
私が悩んでいる私に何とか教えてくださいという人に教えてあげる
だけどそういう仏教ですから
人にあのドアを叩いてね
汝は神を信じますか？とかね
それは仏教ではないんです
大きな世話ですね 人々にとってはそれっていうのは
あなたは三宝に帰依したらいかがでしょうかとかね
まあ私たちもね その他宗教の真似をして
各家にいてピンポン鳴らって
あの実はこのもう三宝
三宝に帰依したらいかがでしょうかとの宣伝に参りましたと
それはもうないんです
人間には人間の生き方っていうのあるんですからね
で それに邪魔してはいけないんです
嫌いというならば そんなことを言ったら罰が当たるぞとかね
それはちょっと失礼でしょうに
嫌いんだったらその人を嫌いだから
では誰に仏教を語るかというと
やっぱり個人が私が知りたいと
私にはいろいろ問題があって
いろんなところに行ってみたんですけど
納得いかなかったと あなた方はどういうふうに答えるのかいと
言ったら まあこういうことですよと
で 教えてあげる で 修行する人々にはもうなおさら教えてあげたりはする
修行しなさい いわゆる実践しなきゃ意味がないんですけど
それも言います 理論は言いますけど
理論は実践で成り立ちますよと
では私は実践していますと言ったらいいですよと
それから方法を教えてあげる
実践している人々にとっては
どんな問題が来ても それからは強引にでも言います
で 厳しく指導するのは
やっぱり仏道にもう入ってね
私はもう仏道に入りますという人々には
もう責任持ってしっかりと育ててみるという風なやり方でやってはいるんですね
仏教はずっと現在まで
いいですか？質問  はい
私ちょっと間違って理解してたかもしれないんですけど
これは阿羅漢が住んでるところならば
他の人がね 楽しいっていうか
楽しいよっていう風にようなものだ
詩のように私は理解してたんですけど
そういうふうには取れません
取れません  そういう解説もできますけど
一応仏教地理学的にも
この私が今説明しているところなんですね
わかりました  だからそういう
そういう可能性もあります
阿羅漢で すごい聖者ですから
だからそこは信仰 信仰的に喋る場合はそうなります
仏教の人々はみんなそう思っているんです
例えば昔 阿羅漢がこのお寺に住んでいましたというだけでも
そのお寺に巡礼に行くんです
すごい清らかな場所だ
聖地だとかね これは仏教の仏教徒たちがやっていることで
それは科学 学問的に見れば明らかに信仰ですね
それはあることは確かにありますしね
しかし お釈迦様が説明したかったのはそれじゃないんですね
で アッターラハントヴィーラって阿羅漢がどこに住んでいるか
その場所がすごい素晴らしい場所であると
だから阿羅漢がこれはすごく居心地のいい
住み心地のいいところだなと住んでいるんですね
阿羅漢がどこに入れていたって
ああ ここはすごく住み心地がよく
良くて 何だ素晴らしい場所ですかと言うんです
だから  その程度の話だと思いますね
それから私が喋っていたのはね
まあだから私たちには阿羅漢というのはそう簡単には理解できないんですけど
もしがするとね まあそうやってどんな場所にも文句言わない人が
もしがすると阿羅漢ではないかなという推測できますけど
危ないんですよ なぜならば
阿羅漢でない人もそんなに場所に文句言わない鈍感な人もいますよ
[笑い]まあどうでもいいやという感じで
だからまたいろいろ方法で調べなくちゃいけないんですね
たったこれだけではわからないでしょう
結局は しかし 一つ私たちにアドバイスになるところも
私たちもこのあまりにも人に文句を言う癖
悪い癖ね 環境が悪い 周りが悪いとかね
それはどうかした方がいいんじゃないんですかね
会社の同僚が悪い 性格が悪いとかね
上司の性格が悪いとかね
夫の性格が悪いとかね
それはすごく性格的に他人に文句を言う場合は
ものすごい自分の性格が悪いんです
あれ 自分の情けないことを言ってるだけなんです
それは理解してないんですね
だから環境に だから全てまとめてから環境という
私はその単語を使いますけど
日本語でその意味かどうか分かりませんだけど
英語ではEnvironmentという言葉を使いますけど
環境ですね それを日本訳すると
人々の環境なんです 私の場合の説明の場合は
自然環境だけじゃないんです
自分住んでるところにイタチが来るならば
それも環境なんですね
蚊がいっぱいいるならば
それも環境ですね だから私の使う特別な単語を特別な意味で使いますけど
環境というのはもう普通物質的な環境だけではなくて
周りにいる生命も入ってます
だから私という存在に対して全て環境なんです
例えばこちらに子供が入ったとしましょう
子供が何人か 入った途端環境変わったでしょ
環境変わりました だから人間も生命も全て入れて環境
だから私たち 私が一人
私が環境に文句を言うと
これは成り立たないんですね
だから答えは環境に文句を言うんじゃなくて
あなたは環境にどう対応するのかと
この対応の仕方によってあなたが結果を得られますよと
それで環境にいつでももう文句を言う場合は
自分がそれなりの結果が得られるんですね
あなたが悪い あなたが悪い
あなたのせいでこうなったとかね
あなたのせいで私は不幸でしたとかいう人は
それにふさわしい結果が得られるんですね
だからどう対応するのかと
ほとんどみんな対応はもう怒りであるいは欲で対応するんですね
あなたがいると楽しいんだから逃げないでくださいとかね
あるいはあなたいるんだからうるさいんだから早く出て行ってくださいとかね
そういうふうに私たちはやっぱりあまりも弱すぎですね
だから仏教が推薦するのは
いかに落ち着いていられるのかということを考えたらどうですかと
それは自分の対応にする
対応方法としてね はい
この環境でどうすれば落ち着くのかと
それではだいたい問題解決しますよ
怒りっぱなしの上司ともうちょっと 10 分ぐらい喋らなくちゃいけない
それ 10 分くらい自分がその環境にいるんですね
はい この 10 分以内で私は落ち着いていなくちゃいけないんだと
で そういう風にもうすぐすぐ時間の経過とともに環境変わりますから
その どのように落ち着いていればいいのかということが自分の宿題としてね
自分の修行の課題として置いておけば
結構うまくいくんじゃないかなと思いますね
それで自分の人格が成長します
向上します それだけで悟りに達するわけじゃないんだけど
やっぱり悟った人の生き方を我々真似するんだから
それで大変幸せにはなります
トラブルは消えていきます
しかし 必ず疲れると思いますよ
だってずっとその宿題が追ってくるんだからね
結構疲れるかもしれませんだけど
いつでもやっぱり落ち着いていようとかね
その対応の仕方ですね
環境にあなたはどんな対応を取るのかという
どんなアプローチで対応するのかということで
自分の結果が決めます
じゃあ落ち着いているではないかと思っちゃえば
かなりそれがすごく素晴らしい対応だと思いますね
なぜならば落ち着いていると
問題が起きても答えが見えてきますね
かなり 失敗しないで有効に生きることはできるようになります
はい そんなところですね
説明はこの芸の はい  99番ありますか？テキスト
だいたいおなじみなんですね ramaniyāni
araññāni yatthana ramatipano vitaraṅgā ramissanti na
te kāma gavesinoramaniyāni
araññāni yatthana ramatipano vitaraṅgā ramissanti na te kāma gavesin
oで言葉の意味見てみましょうか
ramaniyāni
araññāniこの山なんか森なんかとても美しいものであると ramaniya
って何か日本語訳何かいい単語あるんですかね
人のいない 私は森は  次の単語
楽しい  楽しい ramaniya
気に入ったって意味なんですから
何かいい単語があるはずなんですね
もっとかっこいい言葉が
愉快  愉快 ramaniyāni
araññāniこの森とかは愉快な場所であると
で あの  森と言ったって
もう日本であんまり森と言ったってあんまりよくわからないんですね
もう山ですね 日本の場合は
山という言葉使ってますね
だから山は本当に愉快な場所であると
で 大量に森やら山やら日本にありますが
なんとなくみんなちょっとインド文化的に
あるいは自分の国の文化的に思う森という意味がないんですね
インド文化的には森っていうのは本当に怖いところなんです
もう そんなに 怖いんです
あのテレビででもアマゾンの森とかの見たことがあるでしょ？テレビでも見て
こんなところに住めるのかいとちょっと見てください
住めるか もう中に入るのも怖くてね
どこに蛇がいるかわからないし
どんな虫がいるかわからないし
どんな動物が飛んでくるかわからないし
無数にいるんだから いろんな生命が
ジャングルですか  うん
ジャングルですね ジャングルって日本語ですかね
日本語じゃないです  そういうことで
なんかじゃあジャングルにしましょうか
ジャングルっていうのは本当に愉快な場所ですよと
やったね ラマティージャのどんな場所かというと
一般人が愉快だと思わない
もう嫌やと思うんで ラマティー
不愉快ですね 一般人が不愉快やと思ってるこのジャングルは確実に愉快な場所であると
誰が愉快な場所やというかというと
ヴィーターラーが欲から離れた人々が
いわゆる悟った人々ですね
ヴィーターラーがっていうのは阿羅漢のこと
阿羅漢たちがそこですごく愉快な場所だと気に入ってるんだと
居心地がいいんだと思いますよと
だから 前の偈と同じ意味なんですね
ジャングルで住もうかなとは全然思わないね
夢の夢も見ないでしょ
夢ででもちょっと試しにジャングルで住んでみてもいいんですけど
夢も見ないんですね 夢でジャングル見たらもう怯えて夢の中でも逃げるんですからね
で 阿羅漢はそれは愉快な場所であると思っちゃうんですね
次に理欲界 前の偈で理由はなかったんですね
九十九番目その理由を書いてます
ネテーカーマガヴェーシの彼らが欲を探し求めていないんだと
カーマガヴェーシというのは一般人のこと
私たちは欲を探し求めているんですね
欲を探し求める人にとっては
ジャングルというのはもう話になりませんね
断然ダメな場所なんですね
何の欲も得られません
だから一般人がそこはもう不愉快と思っちゃうんです
怖いと気に入らないと気持ち悪いと危ないと
と思う 阿羅漢たちは欲
欲を探し求めてないんです
では 何を探し求めるんですかね？何も
何も探し求めるということはないんです
ということは 極限に落ち着いているということなんです
何か探していること 求めるということは
人間は動かしているんですよ
だから人間には落ち着きがなくて
いつでも何か求めているんですね
求めることで生きているんですね
生きるとは何かというと
何かを求めて走り回ることなんですね
では 求めたものを得たら
次のものを求める それ得たら次のものを求める
それでさらに心は混乱する
求めるということは 心落ち着いてないんですね
不満なんですね だから何か求める
求めたところで 求めたところで不満がなくなりますか？なくなりません
求めたものを得られたところで
ああ よかった 俺ってすごいツイてるんだなとか言って
もう興奮しちゃうんですね
それで心は混乱する あるいは求めたものは得られない
それでまた落ち込んだりする
そこからは逃げられませんね
興奮したり落ち込んだり
興奮したり落ち込んだりという
心にとっては激しいダメージなんです
そこで求めたものは得たならば
次のものを求める 求めたものは得ることができなかったら
失敗したら別なものを求める
同じ結果でしょ だから得ても失敗しても
次のステップは決まっている
別なものを求めるという
面白いんですよ 人間の人生というのは
自分が希望したものに達してしまったら
別なものを希望する 自分が希望したものは大失敗したら別なものを希望する
二人とも同じなんですね
失敗しても成功しても
次のステップは決まっている
それで求めるものは得たところで心が混乱する
求めるものは得られなかったら混乱する
それまた同じなんですね
だから 俗世間では成功すること
求めるものに達することはすごいすごいと言うんだけど
客観的に考えればどっちでも同じことでしょ
心から心を基準にして判断すると
心の立場から見ればどうったことないんですね
ワンパターンなんです
そこは理解するのはちょっと難しいかもしれませんだけど
俗世間の見方と仏教の見方はそういうところで凄い違うんですね
俗世間から見れば 自分が挑戦すること
自分の希望 自分の願望叶うことが人生の成功だと
すごいんだと そのために頑張ろうではないかと思っていて
そこはポジティブシンキングだと思ったりして
それは俗世間の考えですね
希望叶わないことが不幸であると
叶わないと思うこともネガティブシンキングであると
では 心の立場から見てみると
希望があるということは
あなたは落ち着いてない
あなたは不満にいる イライラしている
だからあなたに希望がある
それで希望が叶ったでしょ
叶ったらあんた興奮している
心落ち着いてない それで次あんたどうするのかと
まあ希望が叶ったんだから
もう面白くない それは
新しい希望を作りますよと
いうことになってるんですね
ということは まだ心は落ち着いてない
まだ混乱状態でまだ不満な状態で
では もう一人の人が希望があるということは
あなたに不満がある あんた落ち着いてない
それで希望叶ったんですか？と
いえ 失敗しましたと それで？それですごい落ち込んでいるということは
希望が失敗したんだから
あんたの心は混乱しているでしょうと
あんたは不満がそのままです
あんたどうするの？別な希望に挑戦すると
ということは あなたに不満があるということで
だから両方同じなんですね
希望が叶っても叶わなくても
希望が叶う道を選んでも
希望が叶わない道を選んだっても
結果的に同じ結果なんです
心の状況では そういう難しいことを理解してください
そうすると 仏教を学ぶと頭がよくなると私は言ってるでしょうに
そんなに何で頭がよくなるのを嫌がるかわからないんですね
いつだって頭のいい人はもう勝ちますよ
頭が悪い人が勝つっていうことはありえないでしょう
だから そういう今説明したところはよく覚えてね
理解してください ただ
バカみたくね 希望叶うことに必死で命かけてやるぞと言ったっても
まあそこをなくても負けで負け犬精神でどちらでも大した差がないんだよということをね
同じこっちゃと 心は不安なまんまやと
心は不満であるんだと
はい そういうことで 一般の人々にとっては
この求めるということがあります
結局 偉そうなことを求めてないんです
欲を求めているんです
それしか知らないんです
だから希望があった方がいいやとかね
期待があって 人生があって
高い夢を作ってや 高い希望を作って頑張ろうではないかと
誰にも高い希望は作れないんです
もう情けない希望ばっかしなんです
動物園で飼われている動物はいくらか今もう例えば上の動物にしたっても
動物はすっごく少ないんだけど
その代わりに結構もう人間には想像できないぐらいすごい土地なんですね
虎とかね いろいろライオンとかいるところ
あんな土地計算してみるとどれぐらい値段かかるのかとか
上野でしょうね 虎一匹はどれぐらいの値札がつく土地で住んでいるのかと
じゃあ 人間には叶わない贅沢なんですけど
虎はそれ知らないでしょうしね
そこでこの中でね あの
虎たちが じゃあ元気で明るく生きてみようかなと思ったっても
得なことないでしょ あの小さなところでウロウロウロウロウロウロ回るしかないしね
ちょっとした木みたいなものもあります
それちょっと登ってみたり
そちらで爪をガリガリと削ってみたり
あのシロクマさんがいるところで
こちらガラス張ってあって水があるんですね
そこでドキャンとそちらに飛ぶと
見てる我々びっくりしてね
自分の体の上に飛ぶような感じで見えますからね
これ私たちはそれで騙されるし
後ろから見たら何のこともないちょっとした水があって
それにもう面白く なんとか水に飛び込むと飛び込むだけで
我々人間の希望もそんな程度なんです
ある小さな檻があるんですよ
その中で作る希望なんです
この小さな檻って何なのかというと
眼耳鼻舌身なんです 目耳鼻舌体に触れることを探しているんです
この眼耳鼻舌身の対象を欲というんです
だから心にある欲はまた別で
心にある欲は好き嫌いの差なんですね
欲しいものは欲で 嫌いものは怒りにしていますね
もう一つ 欲が欲というか
パーリ語でちょっと言葉変えますけど
あのあの誤解する場合はちょっと誤解しないように言葉入れますけど
この場合はその言葉を入れてないんです
芸ですからね で入らないんです
この場合は本当はパーリ語でカーマワットという単語なんです
カーマだけではないんです
それで私たちは希望が希望を作る
夢を作ると言ったっても
全て眼耳鼻舌身に関わるものなんです
私の夢はアメリカで土地を買って
家を買って生活 スイミングプールついてる家買うことやという希望があるとしましょう
これ例え話です 私にはそんな希望あるんだと言ってインターネットで書いたっても意味がないんです
で 私の希望はアメリカでスイミングプールついてる家を買うことやと
何のこっちゃですかね
それが結局は眼耳鼻舌身のものでしょ
大したことはないんです
他 希望は作ったことないでしょうに
だから人間が眼耳鼻舌身に触れることを探し求めているんだから
ジャングルはちょっとごめんですね
ジャングルにも眼耳鼻舌身ありますけど
ジャングルにも蛇もいるし
蚊もいるし やっぱり体にも触れたりするでしょうに
人を刺す毒持っている昆虫たちもいるし
相当眼耳鼻舌身に触れる情報ありますけど
やっぱりそれは人間好むものじゃないんですね
ですから危ないとかね
危険だとか思ったりするんです
阿羅漢の人間に理解できないところは
もう何も求めていないということがすごく理解しにくいんですね
眼耳鼻舌身に関わるものって何も求めてないんですね
だから無常に生きるということで生きてますからね
この偈で我々は勉強するべきことが一言あります
前の偈からはやっぱり環境に文句言わないで落ち着いて落ち着くことを宿題にしましょうということ
この偈でこの求めるところに宿題が出てくるんです
私たちが日常求めるものっていうのは
情けない動物園の動物と大した変わりがないんだと
情けないと 金を求めるでしょ？何単純な眼耳鼻舌身でしょ
立場が何か社会的立場が欲しがるでしょ
単純に眼耳鼻舌身なんです
総理大臣になろうと思ったっても
国会議員になろうと思ったっても
課長になろうと思ったってもね
ただの眼耳鼻舌身の求めであって
自分の環境で希望を作るだけ
だから自分知ってる環境ででしょ
だから子供たちに聞いてみる
聞いてみれば あなた将来何になりますかと
子供たちはダラダラと答えるでしょう
随分大きい声で 何のこともないんだ
子供たちがその自分の環境で知ってることばっかしなんです
で 毎日のように電車見える電車に乗っている男の子なら
もう電車の運転士になりたいと思っちゃうんです
電車に乗ったことがない子はそうは言いませんね
だから子供の世界を見ると
この人間の希望の狭さ
よく見えるんです 幼稚園の子供に大きくなったらどうなると聞いたら
自分知ってる環境の中で女の子だったらお母さんになりたいとかね
あれやこれやとか どうもうなんとか
そこら辺のことを言うんですね
小さな女の子に私も聞いたことありますから
あんた大きなどうなる？お嫁さんになりたいと
言われたんです でお嫁さんって何よ？知ってる？知らないでしょうに
何でそうなったかというと
やっぱり自分のお母さんがお父さんのお嫁さんなんですね
それ知ってるんですね
そこでお母さんの立場が強くて
全部支配していて この子も女の子だからね
支配されるのは嫌なんですね
自分も支配する側に入りたいんですね
ですから 大きくなったらお嫁さんになると
もう決まってるんです
そこでちょこちょこっと幼稚園に行ったり
小学校に行ったりすると
またあの夢が変わっていくんですね
だから人間作る夢っていうのは
自分が入ってる檻の中から一つ選ぶだけなんです
だから動物園にいる動物とは変わってないんです
動物園には物理的な檻があるんだから違うだろうと腹が立つでしょ
私がそんなこと言ったら
私たちも檻があるんですよ
眼耳鼻舌身の檻があってね
例えば皆様の場合は いくら夢があっても日銀の総裁になりたいという夢がないでしょう
おそらく 自分の檻から外だからね
[笑い]自分の檻から外のものは希望しません
夢 夢も見ません  そんなもんなんです
夢っていうのは本当に情けないんです
あまりにも小さくて だからこの求める場合は
私たちは何かもうちょっとかっこいいものを求めたらどうでしょうかと
そこは勉強してください
これは金持ちになるとかね
子供をしっかり教育させるとかね
こんなのはちっぽけな希望やと
自分の子はもうサッカー好きで
もうサッカーチームに何としてでも入れるようにしてあげなくちゃとかね
そんなのはもの 檻の中の夢なんですね
子供がサッカー大嫌いだったら
その夢作らないんですね
だからこれはお母さんの夢だよっていうことはどうったことはないんです
だからそんなにそれを夢にするんだから大変なんです
あの 大体得られないんです
だってでっかいでしょ
夢が なんだそんなちっぽけなっていう感じで見ると
何のことなくそれを達しますよ
そんなバカバカらしい夢でまあしょうがないっていう
どうったことはないと
それぐらいはと だから
俗世間の違うところは夢持ちましょう
希望を持ちましょう 希望を持って明るく元気で頑張りましょう
それほどネガティブ言葉がないんです
夢持ったってもろくでもない夢でしょうに
これすごいデッカく持っちゃうと叶わないでしょうに
それで必死で苦労しなくちゃあかんでしょうに
そんなちっぽけな夢なんかはって感じでいると
何のことなくそこはもう淡々淡々と
あの 通過することはできます
もっとかっこいい夢ってないんですかね
じゃあ一人一人に聞くしかないんですね
あなたの夢は何ですかと
聞きません これ失礼ですからね
だからあの 自分で自問してみてください
真面目に自問すると私わかります
私の夢って何なのかと
これいい訓練になりますよ
真面目に私の夢って何？と自分に自問してみたら
夢見つかったらありがたいんですけど
これってすごいことですかねとかね
なんでそんなもんかいと
ちっぽけな夢でしょうにってわかったら
そんな夢っていうのは叶うっていうことはね
大きな問題じゃないんです
だからこの俗世間で夢が叶う成功の人生な仏教からなんであさみしまいのことでしょうにと
それに挑戦するバカがいるのかいと
ほら ちょっとのことでできることでしょうに
挑戦すると もう命かけて頑張るぞとかね
子供たちでもはちまきと何とか巻いて必勝とか書いて受験に
なんでバカバカらしいという
もうちっぽけなことでしょうに
すっごいシンプルでしょうに
あれでっかくなるんだからね
他頭が悪くて何も知らないんだから
持ってる夢がガクーンと大きくなっちゃうんですね
だから例えばね ちょっと大型の風船がありますね
あれは空気が入ってないともう 100個でも1万個でもこの部屋の中に入れるでしょ
あるいは外で 1個だけガクンと膨らませちゃうと
もう入れませんね 1個でも
だからね  2メートルぐらい大きくなる風船がありますからね
これ外で空気を入れちゃうともう入りません
だから夢膨らませちゃうと終わりですよもう
そんなに 2メートルぐらい大きくなる風船っていうのは箱ごとに持ってこられるし
部屋の中には 箱ごと持ってきて
適当に膨らませてみる
必要に応じて 楽ちんでしょ
個だけ夢持って それは玄関で膨らませちゃうと
もう終わり もう中に入れようと思っちゃうと
もう張れます 割れてしまいます
弾けてしまいます あ なんて不幸やと
じゃあ次の夢とまた膨らませちゃうと
だから仏教的に見ると
もう人間が思う夢っていうのはちっぽけな夢で
これは適当に膨らましたり
あるいはまた空気を抜けたり
いろいろ何でもできます
あるいは空気入れるポンプも持ってきて
もうもう個でっかい風船を膨らませて
もうもうもう爆発してみるぞと思ったら
部屋の中できるでしょうに
それで外で個も膨らませちゃって
部屋の中で爆発したいんですね
できるわけないでしょ
はい そういうことで 人間の日常の夢っていうのは
すごく小さくてどうったことはない
まあ当たり前のちっぽけな
まあ話にならない夢であると思っちゃえばどうですかね
話題にもなりませんと
で 頑張る気にもならない小さな夢やと
受験なんかそんなどうったことないでしょうにと
ただの受験でしょうにと
そう言わないでしょ 親が
なんだってただの受験でしょうに
これもう昔もみんなやってることや
そんな偉そうなことを言うなよと
ただの受験だからと そういう風に言うと
子供はなんだ そんなちっぽけなことかと
向かってもこれもできなかったらこれまずいと思って勉強するでしょうに
褒めてもらうほどのことじゃないよとこれはと
そういうことで 私の夢は何なのかと
まず自分した方がいいんです
そうすると自分にはちっぽけな夢であると見える
それだけでは日常生活はうまくいく
次 そんなかっこ悪い人には言えますけど
まあもっと品格のある
難しい ちょっと挑戦しなきゃできない夢がないのかと言うと
世の中ではないんですね
格好夢はないんです 仏教以外は
で ということは 例えば西洋の方々はキリスト教でしょう
夢って何ですか？というと
本当にバカバカにして金持ちになることとか
ただそれだけ 本当はね
こちら来る前に映画一本見てきたんです
その映画は何ですか？というタイトル忘れちゃったんですけど
ある女の人がこのすごい正確なような人で
ちょこっと店で仕事をしているで
店の ガチャガチャガチャガチャ悪口言われて
もうあれやこれやとかね
それで彼女が突然倒れちゃって
もう彼女のこと好きな男もいて
それもう病院に連れて行ったら
もうCT撮ってみたら
もう何かガンだと 脳に
これはなんとかなんとかなもあったんだけど
それがもうこの広げ状態見たらね
もうせいぜい 1週  2週間だよと
それなんでそんなこと
私すごい元気で何のこともないでしょうと
それはそういう残念ですと
1週間って まあ 1週間
じゃあ 3週間でしょうという
で 彼女がもうそれで別な病院でも同じデータ見て
見たらもうしょうがないと
それでもう彼女は生活
あのまず店に行ってね
いつでも悪口言う人の電話も全部潰しちゃって
あの話がありますよ この人は話聞かない
あんた仕事しない その前に私の話聞きなさいと
聞かない ただ携帯が鳴ったら携帯取ったんだから
まず携帯喋ってください
終わった途端 彼女は携帯 3台あり
全部これ会社のものやと
あなたの給料からもう天引きしますよ
もうもうしょうがない
はい どうぞと 自由にやってくださいと
あれやこれやと言って
もう会社も辞めちゃって
で ありったけのお金を全部取り出しちゃって
それからお母さんからもらったこのボンズという株ですね
全部一発で全部売り売って
お金持ってもう遊びに行くんですね
で すごい高級ホテルに行って
これあのヘリで行くんです
あの山に そこでいろんな議員さん
あれやこれやがあったりとか
そういう話なんですね
はちゃめちゃ生きてみるんですね
それで後であのあれ 機械は故障していたんだと
後で最後に あなた病気じゃありませんという答えでしたけど
だからそれ見ながらバカバカらしくて
1週間で死ぬと言ったところで
人間の希望ってそんなもんかと
究極に贅沢をするという
情けない しかし もう一つメッセージがあったんですけども
遠慮しないで生きてみましょうよと
怖いあれやこれやと考えないで
言いたい放題のこと言ってね
そこでむちゃくちゃ悪口を言うんです
議員さんたちに集めていたこの女遊びするあれやこれやとかね
で だからちょっと見方変えれば
人間はものすごく明るくなりますよという話もありましたけど
で 遠慮して遠慮して 左見て右見て上見て下見て
惨めな生き方って何でか
どうったことはない 死ぬでしょうに
だから自由に明るく生きてみましょうというメッセージは確かにありましたけど
だから逆に私は考えてみたら
人間って夢ってのはそんなもんかいと
究極の金持ちだけ行くレストラン
ホテルで泊まったんだからといって
だから何ですかと やっぱり西洋の的な思考ではね
夢ってそんなもんなんですね
アメリカンドリームということ？ドリームでしたっけ
言葉もあるでしょうね
本当にバカバカらしいドリームですね
それで何かになるんですかね
そんなはちゃむちゃくちゃ金があったんだからといって何するんですかね
だからそういうものにやらせたらダメですよ
人間が そんなドリームがあったっても
明るくて元気で精一杯生きてないでしょうに
言いたいこと言えないでしょうに
で 金持ちになればなるほど厳しい生活でしょ
行儀作法やらあれやこれやとか
もうその人の社会的にみんな偉いんだからね
大変ですけど 自由に生きていられませんでしょうに
だから結局は西洋の文化から見ても
人間持つべきドリームは何なのかと
何もない ちっぽけなドリーム以外は
じゃあ中国人のドリームは何なのかって何のこともない
ちっぽけなドリーム以外はとにかく金儲かりたいと
むちゃくちゃ儲かりたい
それであんたどうするのかいと
言うと 便所まで金で作るだけ
便座が金 純金になったんだから出て何か違いますかね
まあ確実ありますよ 香港でしたっけ？どこかに
それでも車も高級無茶高給車注文して買ったりするんですけど
で また莫大なお金払って
この番号までも語呂合わせで幸福になる番号
幸福と中国語で読める数字入れたりして
こいつはまだ幸福になりたいんですからね
だからなんですかね だから宗教から見てドリーム作れますかね
キリスト教のドリームって
まあ正真正銘の神を信じる真面目な信徒だとしましょう
あの ほぼキリスト教の世界でないんだけど
ローマ教皇もキリストは信じてないんだけど
それを置いておいて あの
一応理想的に神を信じてる人がいるとしましょう
そうすると 神の審判でやられないことだけでしょ
夢は 神ってとんでもない調子者で
何するかわからない 悪いこと以外何もやりません
で 最後の審判があって
そこで永遠の地獄に陥れないようにと気をつけて
もう神に愛されて天国に生まれるようにと考えることでしょうね
それだけ だから早く死んだ方がマシということでしょうね
じゃあ浄土系のいくつかの宗派がありますけど
真面目に阿弥陀様を信仰する人がいるとしましょう
自分の宗教 阿弥陀信仰は真面目
そうするとその人のドリームって何ですかね
往生することでしょう
じゃあ今やったらどうですかね
それだったら すぐ早く極楽道で
だから だからどんな宗教も同じことなんです
ヒンドゥー教にしたっても
だから俗世間にしたってもかっこいいドリームはないんです
世の中にある宗教にしたっても
かっこいいドリームというのはないんです
だから仏教以外と言ったんです
仏教は現実主義だからね
あんた性格悪いでしょうに
だから心汚いでしょうにと
ちょっとしたことで誘惑されるでしょうにと
ちょっとのことで揺らぐでしょう
あんたの心は 世の中の当たり前のことも
あなたに認める能力ないでしょうにと
例えば生老病死っていうのは当たり前でしょ
自然災害っていうのは当たり前でしょ
認められないんですね
愛する人が死に別れるとか
そんなのは世の中の常識でしょうに
会社が仕事はうまくやったつもりなんですけど
リストラになったとかね
っていうのは世の中の当たり前のこと
でもあんたに認められないでしょ
受け入れられないでしょう
っていうのはブッダの現実的な話なんです
もう何て言いますか あれは
パーリ語で言えば この地方方向も忘れちゃって
頭が混乱 方向感覚まで忘れて頭が混乱するんだっていうお釈迦様の言葉ありますけど
なんか適当な日本語もあると思いますね
途方に暮れるというね
おなじみでね ちょっと誰か死んじゃったら途方に暮れちゃうしね
なんだこれと だから 世の中の当たり前に起こる出来事に揺らがないようにしたらどうですか
当たり前のことを当たり前で見たらどうですかねと
当たり前のことを当たり前で受け取れない
この情けなささ この心の弱さ
このへりくつ この矛盾
性格的な問題でしょ もう信じられない無知なんですね
気に入ってる人は恋人ができまくっても
途中で喧嘩してもう二度と口きくなよと別れることもあり得る
だから恋人できたんだからって舞い上がることもしないで
喧嘩して出て行ったらはいさようならと
で 冷静にいることできないでしょうに
で なんで私に限ってと疑問するでしょ
あんたの人相がもう機能していないんだよと
もう両方もう取り出さなくちゃいけないんだと
なんで私に限ってと聞くんです
そんな話医者知らん そんなのは
病気だから病気と言っただけで
ガンだからガンだと言っただけで
なんで私に限ってガンになるのかい？とかね
いうところなんです ブッダが教えているのは
これ現実なんです 現実を見ないことにする
なかったことにする ないがしろにする
で 生きるということは無知で生きることでしょうに
はい そこを直ちゃえばどうですかと
それがお釈迦様が推薦する夢なんです
希望なんです 心育ててみるぞと
怒らない人間になってやるぞと
優柔不断をなくしてやるぞと
無知な人間にはなれんと
現実はそのまんま受け入れる人間になってやるぞ
あれやこれや 世の中の情報に心揺らげることはなくしてやるぞと
これが私の夢だと これ相当難しいんだと
これから挑戦するぞと言ったら
一生挑戦できるんです
怒らないということに挑戦したら
もう毎日の仕事です 毎日というか
毎時の仕事なんです だっていつ怒りが湧いてくるかわからないでしょ
だから二四時間気をつけて挑戦しなくちゃいけない夢を作ったらどうですかと
受験なんか二四時間じゃないでしょうに
終わったら終わりでしょうに
そういうことで人格向上すると
わかりやすく言えばね
それが人間が作るべき夢なんですね
求めるという言葉 探し求める
だからこのくだらないことを探し求めるんではなくて
人格向上するんだということを求める
一般人にお釈迦様が提案するでっかい夢なんです
これが素晴らしい超越した夢なんです
誰がその夢持ったっても
誰にも迷惑はないんです
一人が自分のドリームを叶おうとすると
大勢の人々には迷惑なんです
で 例えば自分の趣味が釣りだと
とにかく記録を作りたいと思っちゃうと
どれほど魚殺されますかね
そこで記録的に何か釣りを魚を捕ったと思ったっても
次の日別の人もうちょっと一センチ長い魚を取るでしょうね
で あっけなく自分の夢が消えちゃいますね
で ボクシングでベルト取りたいと
むちゃくちゃ苦労してベルト取ったっても
もう三ヶ月間でまた挑戦しなくちゃいけない
別のやつが出ているんです
必ずそいつは年下なんです
やられます 一年間ベルト守ることも大変です
だからベルト取る人々は必ず負けるでしょう
ある時は だから結局は何か恥ずかしいことにあって
はい 私はこれっきり引退すると言わなくちゃいけないんです
一人もスポーツマンはものすごい明るく引退できないんですね
なんかもうこれ以上は年で体が動かないっていうことで
泣きながら引退しなくちゃいけないんですね
惨めで だからそんなのは夢じゃないでしょうに
そういうわけで怒らないこととかね
優柔不断にならないよとかね
心はあれやこれやで誘惑しないで冷静に保ってやるぞということを夢にして
それにはやっぱり時間挑戦しなくちゃいけない
しかし そこは誰にも奪うことできないんです
いつでも自分には勝て
自分に勝てる方法はあります
例えば怒らないことにしたところで
で 私はいろいろなことを言って怒らせようとするでしょ
あなたそんなこと言うんだから怒っちゃったんだよと言って
それはないでしょうに
で 私が怒られることを言えば言うほど
じゃあ怒らないことにするぞと言ったら
怒らないことにしてやるぞと
どうぞ言ってくださいと
で 勝つでしょ 自分が必ず
それは誰にも奪えませんね
だから一番格好夢っていうのはそれなんです
その夢も 알아かになったら終わりです
求めるものはないんです
もう人格は完成しているんです
で  알아かになるまでの夢はそれなんです
他の俗世間の夢なんかは
こんなちっぽけな恥ずかしいやという感じでしてください
そんなのはすごい簡単ですよ
商売繁盛とか家内安全とかなんだこれ？ちょっとしたことできることでしょうね
学業成就とか  [笑い]誰にもできることでしょうに
で そういう風に人生見た方が想像できないほど明るい人間になります
はい これは我々が勉強する
この芸ではなかなか勉強になるもの見つかりっこないんです
荒唐なこと言ってますけどね
しかし そういう風に何か見つかることはできます
ということで  二つ終わりましたからね
そこら辺で終了しましょう
あまりたくさん喋っちゃうと
はい 質問コーナーにします
はい 後ろ マイクロフォン
はい すいませんが もらっていただけますか
お願いします 日本人が知らないブッダの話の本の中で
アジャータサット王のせいで父親が死にました
母殺し 父殺しの大罪を犯すと
根絶やささるのは無理と言われます
ですけども このアジャータサットは大ストーパを献上し
建立し 生涯にわたって仏教教団をサポートし続けましたと言ってました
ですけど ここでお釈迦様と出会ったことで道は開けたのですとあります
道は開けたということはどういう状態のことなのか
道は開けなかったならばどういう状態になるのでしょうか
この大罪を犯した場合
集中ができないので悟れないのですって
先生とおっしゃる この間おっしゃっていたようなもんですけれども
ヴィパッサナー修行は全くできないのでしょうか？ということが一つです
アジャータサット王がこのストゥーパを建立とか
仏教をサポートしたということは
四正法の不殺 愛の修行
行持を行ったということになるのでしょうか
もう一つはですね アーナンダ尊者が修行が進んでいない時に不倫をして地獄へ行って
順々にまた人間へ戻ってくる話があったので
私は不倫をしたら地獄へ行くと思っていたので
下品の人に話をしたんです
そうしましたら 後で比丘の方に殺人をしなければ殺人をした時だけ地獄へ行くと聞きました
それで これ不倫の状況によるのかどうのかって
私ちょっと話してしまったので
ちょっと責任があるんですね
どこら辺が聞きたいんです
この前 前ですが 日本のお坊さんが奥さんと愛人と一緒に住んでいるっていう話も聞いたことがあるんですけれども
それからもう一つ 地獄の話で
2007 年頃の月例講演でスマナサーラ長老がお金持ちの人が何回も結婚して輪廻しないで亡くなった即時の経験です
残された人たちが悲惨争いするからですという話を聞いたことがあります
大罪を犯しても よくある悟れなくても
四正法で精一杯することにより地獄へ行かないのか
道は開けるってどういうことなのかなということを知りたいと思います
よろしくお願いいたします
全然わからないんですけど
アーナンダ尊者のあの話ってあったっけ？ それは私にもよくわからないんですけど
テーラワーダの話じゃないでしょ
ジャータカの話ですか
なんか不倫をして なんかありましたっけ？その話
なんか書いてあった気もしますね
日本人が知らないブッダの話
ジャータカにアーナンダ尊者のうんぬんはなかったと思います
そうか ちょっと アジャスヨの話は一応書きましたけど
ね その本ではね 全部テキストにあるものしか書いてないでしょ
はい  なんか私たちが知らない話はいっぱい出ましたけど
アーナンダ尊者の不倫の話なんかはちょっと
本にあったんですかね
そんな話は  本ではなくて
ジャータカ物語かなんかのような感じで聞いたように思うんですよね
それは本当のアレじゃないんですか？ ジャータカ物語は物語ですから
道徳を知るために うん
だから日本人知らないブッダの話の場合はアジャスヨのストーリーは一応経典に出てくるストーリーだから
それはちゃんと書きたいと書いたと思いますけど
で アジャスヨのアジャータサットですね
アジャータサットが父親を殺しちゃったんだから
やっぱりデーヴァダッタの話を聞いてね
まあ別な宗教を作っていたんですね
デーヴァダッタ教みたいなもの
だから まあ一応デーヴァダッタさんもね
ブッダのところで出家したんですけど
自分が別な教えを説いてやっていたんだから
なんか新興宗教みたいな形ですね
しかし お釈迦様から見れば
ジャラサトっていうのは若者でね
お釈迦様と殺されたマカダ国王がね
同じ歳でね とにかく彼がね
お釈迦様に会って話したりして付き合ったことはなかったんですね
そこでデーヴァダッタも死んじゃったし
自分が大事な父親を殺してずっと悩んでいたし
なんか宗教からでも心を慰める方法はないのかといったところで
インドの宗教は全部試していたし
ブッダ以外は ブッダの敵的に宗教で信仰して失敗してしまったからね
ブッダのところに行かないんで
だから強引に連れて行ったんですね
やっぱりジーヴァカ王様が
ジーヴァカ医者が 強引に連れて行って会わせたんですね
そこでやっと心の悩みがなくなったんです
ただ お坊さん 比丘たちを見ただけで
本人がすーっと心が落ち着いてしまっちゃったんです
なぜかというと すごい恐怖感にいた人が
どれほど恐怖感だというと
この午後出る羽目になっちゃったんですね
午後出るときは象に乗って行ったんだけど
男は信頼できないんだと
だから警備やってるのはみんな男装した女性たちなんです
で 王様が座っている像にも後ろに座っているのは女性なんですけど
男の格好をして武器を持っていると
それぐらいもう臆病というか
自分の命を心配していたんですね
それでお釈迦様と1500人ぐらいのお坊さんたちが住んでいるところと言って近寄ってみたら
喉が鳴らす声さえも聞こえないんです
こちらで1500人の比丘たちと一般在家の人々は大勢いるんでしょうかと
まるっきり誰もいない森に
もう公園でしたけど 私を騙して
このジーヴァカ医者がね
騙されて誰かに言われて暗殺させようではないかと思って
これでいくら女性の兵隊さんに囲まれていても意味がないんだから
もう汗が出て震えちゃったんですね
だからそこでどれほど怖い精神でいたかったよね
それでジーヴァカ医者が 「
あのね もうちょっと像から降りて進んでみてください」と 「
怖がる必要はないんだ」と
言うと 像から降りて行ったら
やっぱりいるんですよ
大勢の人々が こんなにたくさん人がいるのに
誰に 咳払いもしない くしゃみもしない
そこであの真ん中に座っているのはそのお釈迦様ですよと
それ見ただけで王様には信じられないね
この雰囲気は この落ち着きはと
言ってお釈迦様にさあというところに行って
心の中でこの落ち着きは私の息子にもあればありがたいと
自分にも小さな子供がいたんですね
でお釈迦様はパーリ語で別な単語で言ったんですけど
日本語に訳すると あなたも結局は親バカですねということ意味の言葉を言ったのお釈迦様は
だから本人は口で言ってないんです
何も口で言ってないんだけど
こう見て子供のことを思い出すんですね
思い出すたら あなたも一応親バカですねと
そこですごく落ち着いて
実はそうなんですよと
息子のためならもう何でもやりますよと
それはさらに厳しい だから自分の父親も自分をそのように育てたんですね
その人を殺しちゃったんですね
それでそれと関係なく別な質問をされて
それに答えたのは長部経典の2番目の経典ですよ
長い経典ですよ だから大事な歴史的な出来事だから
全部丁寧に記録してあります
それでアジャータサットさんが人間として歩むべき道を発見したんです
仏教っていうのはすごい現実的で
目の前で結果出す信仰ではない教えであると分かったんです
で 分かって そこで初めて
じゃあ私は今日からブッダの教えに従って生きてみますと
で 仏教徒になるんですね
それで本人の道でしょうに
本人が完璧にブッダを信仰して
法仏法僧を信仰して 仏教徒になって
仏教のウパーサカになって話し終わってからもう帰るんですね
帰るときお釈迦様があの子はね
あの父親を殺さなかったら座って
立つ時は預流果に達して立ちますよと
だから一般凡夫がいて
お釈迦様のところに座る
座って話を聞いて立って帰る時はもう聖者の仲間入りして帰るんですよ
それぐらいブッダの言葉に迫力あるんです
今この場で悟る能力はありましたよとこの子には
だからすごい頭のいい子なんですよ
子と言ったら王様なんですね
お釈迦様から見れば子供ですからね
だから頭が良くて すごいしっかり育てられた人で
やっぱり父親を殺した罪が邪魔して
頭が集中力は出てこないんですね
だからやっぱり罪を犯したら
それは心に記録されますから
それはぐるぐるぐるぐるぐるぐる回ってきますよ
だからあの親を殺すと
もうこれはもうダメになります
なんでみんなそんなシンプルなことを誤解するのか
困るのかよくわかりませんだけど
だから仏教の説明では
五逆罪を起こしちゃうと
一個でも その根性 根性というかね
その生まれでは悟りに達しません
もう心に入ったひび割れがあまりも多すぎて
微妙なひび割れだったらちょっとボンドでは何とかできますけど
あまりにもひび割れが入っちゃうと
もう修復できません だからこの逆罪一個でも起こしたら
その生まれでは悟りに達しない
瞑想しても第一禅定も生まれてこない
その人は永久的に地獄に落ちるんだという話じゃないんです
今世は失敗 それだけ 来世まで失敗とは言わないんです
そこで五逆罪を起こした人が次もう地獄に落ちるんです
もう決まってます もう地獄に行くことはもう定まっている
定めているんです 地獄に落ちたって
もう地獄も我々の世界と同じく寿命というものあるんです
輪廻転生の中で永遠っていうのはありえないんです
天国に行ったっても 天人たちには寿命があるんです
寿命終わったら死ぬんです
それだけのことで だから地獄に落ちる
で 落ちちゃったら地獄の状況って大変だから
もう苦しみだけで極限に苦しみだけで
で これでもう寿命が終わったら地獄で死にます
死んだら別なところで生まれ変わります
それからもうあの罪はもうひとかけらもなくもう忘れてるんですね
もうそれなりに償いもしましたし
ですから  大丈夫っていうことなんです
だからアジャセオが仏教には偉大なるすごい貢献したんです
お釈迦様に対してもう反対やっていた人なんですけど
若者でしょうし 一旦わかったらすごい活動なんですね
それからはものすごいしっかりともう仏教
後の次の時代にまで残るようにと
あれやこれやと色々協力はしましたし
それはすごい善行でしょうに
だから彼がブッダに会ったこと
ブッダを自分の父親の代わりにしたこと
仏教を守ってあげたこと
第一結集は自分で全部やってあげたこととかね
お釈迦様の面倒をずっと見てあげたし
タラも作ってあげたし
もう信じられないぐらい徳を積んだでしょうに
だから死んだら地獄に落ちて
その罪終わったら次にどこへ行くのかというと
それから徳しか残ってないでしょうに
それからどこかいいところで天国とかね
生まれるでしょう もしかすると人間に生まれても
とっくに悟りに達して涅槃に入っている可能性もあります
知りません ないと思いますけど
地獄の寿命はもっと長いんです
また亡くなられてもう三年も経ってないんだから
もっと長いんです まだいると思いますけど
だから将来はやっぱりあれほどブッダにブッダのことを信頼していたんだから
まあ必ず解脱に達するでしょう
ダイブダッタも同じなんです
ダイブダッタもあんな性格悪かったんだけど
どこかでまた真面目なんです
どこかでブッダの真理はもうすごい正しいと
これこそ正しいと また知ってるんですね
だから彼も五逆罪を犯したんだから地獄に落ちたんですね
しかし お釈迦様は彼のことを予言しているみたいんですね
彼が将来独覚仏陀になりますよと
いわゆる一人で頑張って悟りに達しますよと
[外国語]どうしても自分の道を歩みたい性格なんです
みんなと一緒に活動したくないんですね
だから一匹狼主義なんですね
そういうわけで 彼がやっぱりいろいろアホなことを大きな罪を犯しましたけど
やっぱりそれでもあいつはね
かなりブッダの教えに対しては確信がありますからね
遠い未来 独覚 一人で悟る
人に教えません ブッダになりますと予言してますから
仏教では永遠に地獄に落ちるという話がない
大体そんな程度の話なんです
だから阿闍世は道を開けたっていうことは
だから生きる道を見つけました
お釈迦様にあってから
それだけの話を他のたくさん質問されましたけど
他に訳がわからなくなっちゃったわけです
あのテキスト持ってきたんで
何かあったっけ？あんなそうじゃない
いや 不倫して地獄がどうのって話は
不倫がどうのって話は持ってないです
だから不倫したら地獄に落ちるんじゃなくて
罪を犯したらもう地獄に落ちますよ
だからそれ罪の程度になりますからね
罪はどんな人間も罪を犯しますよ
一般人で罪を犯さない人間っていうのはありえないし
だから罪を犯しても自分が悪人になったかないかって問題なんですね
誰でも悪いことをいろいろやってますけど
悪人になったわけじゃないでしょうに
だから悪人になってしまえば
どんな罪でも地獄直行ですよ
直行っていうのはちょっと言い過ぎなんですけど
だから罪の程度なんです
程度というか 心の受け止め方なんですね
不倫に限ったものじゃないんです
たまたま不倫したっても
誰にも迷惑かけてないとかね
もう家族を悩ませないとかね
もうちゃんと責任果たしてしっかりと生きてる人っていうのは
別にその悪人ということでもないでしょうに
たまたまそういう環境があって
もう誘惑されちゃってやられちゃったという
普通どんな人間持ってる？心の弱みでしょう
それであなたの一生は決めましたっていうことはありえないんです
ではなくて 不倫は自分の道であってね
お前黙っていろよとかね
子供がお金がないというと
お前らあげるお金がないんだぞとかね
言って 自分の収入でいろんな女にお金あげたりプレゼントあげたりして
それは自分の人生になっちゃうと
もう悪人そのものでしょう
悪人になってしまえば
もう知ったことじゃないんですね
だから誰でも罪を犯しますからね
で 犯すんだけど 悪人になったわけじゃないんですね
だからまあ犯した悪いことを別に置いておいて
自分がいいことをして生活すれば
いい人間になってやるぞという風に精進する気持ちさえあれば
別に地獄に落ちません
いろいろ私はだらしないんだけど
それでもいくらだらけなくて
いくら失敗したっても
いい人間にはなりますとか
いい人間になるように頑張りますとかね
決めておけば 死後は地獄に落ちません
今日何か思い出した例えなんですけど
この戒律の問題でいつでも質問されますからね
私も時々一人で考える時もあります
今日はちょっとあの ちょこっと一人で考えた時ね
この前 殺生について質問されちゃって
長い時間かかって答えましたけどね
で 私はその答えにも自分があまり満足してないんです
ちょっとなんか私の返事もなんか曖昧中途半端だなというね
不満もありましたし で
私は今日考えたのは この殺生ってややこしい戒律でみんな引っかかっていて
考えてみれば嘘にしたっても同じややこしい戒律なんですね
日本では嘘をつかないで生活できます
私は思ったのはこの例えなんですね
あの第二次世界戦争の時のドイツを考えてみましょうと
これ ヒットラーがユダヤ人を捕まっては殺す
捕まっては殺すと そこであるドイツ人が
これ実際にあったことだからね
自分知っているユダヤ人を家の中でベースメント
地下で隠しておく 一人のユダヤ人の分厚い本を読んだことがありまして
もう何ヶ月かもある人の家で地下を掘って
生活していたんだと その地下掘ってそちらにいる時でも
ちょっとしたあれで子供たちに数学やらいろいろなことを教えていたんだと
だから体が地下 もう土ですから
壁もね 水が漏れたりして
ドイツとまた寒い すごい寒いしね
それですごく体も病気になったり
色々あったりしても 外へ出ることはできない
しかし その当時はドイツ人の土地で
そこで囲まっているんですね
で 食べ物とか何とか入れてくれるし
便所もその中でやらなくちゃいけないし
だから結構ひどい目に遭いましたと
はい そういうケース これ現実にあったケース
その人々もユダヤ人が何か名誉勲章をあげるんですね
名誉勲章をもらったんです
で ヒットラーの兵隊さんが来るでしょ
調べに あんた方誰かくまってないんですかとか
片っ端から家調べたりするでしょ
何回何回も兵隊も来るんですね
来るとその家の人々はどう言う？はい
私は家族 4人かくまってますよと言う？言わないでしょ
全くもう堂々と嘘を言うでしょ
何考えてるの？我々はヘイルヒットラーと言いながらね
ヒットラーのためにやってるんではないかと
侮辱やとこれも言う かくまうのは
かくまってあげるわけないでしょ
あんなネズミたちをとかね
言うでしょうに だからそれで
その人々は明らかに嘘を言っていて
だからそこはどう判断するべきがいいかと私は考えたんです
それで嘘をついたんだから地獄に落ちるとか話にならんでしょうに
その人々もやっぱり人の命を守るために
やっぱり場合によって嘘もつく
目的なんですね 罪か罪にならないかということ
これはすごい人間を守ってあげようと
こんな残酷な殺し方ってとんでもないやと思って
ユダヤ人を守ってあげようとしているんですね
だから嘘はつく それは罪になるのかいと
だからそういうことだから
この そんな簡単には判断できませんよ
もう一人 日本で医者がね
なんか誰かの耳の中で虫が入っていて見つけたんだと
で ひどいことそれ放っておけば
人が死んじゃいますから
で 自分がもう残酷に虫を全部片っ端から殺しちゃったと
殺して耳をきれいにして治療してあげたと
それで私に聞くんですね
やっぱりあれってなんか殺生だなと自分が思っちゃったんだと
それで私は はい あんた殺生しましたと
命たるものは誰でも殺したらあかんやと
言える そんなことは だからその時私はもう私なりに
やっぱりあなたはあなたの仕事をしてくれ
あなたの仕事は人間を守ってあげることでしょうにと
余計なことを考えるなよと
虫も生き物ですよとかね
変な科学知識でね 虫についてもよく知ってて
どんな虫か どんな種類かとかね
虫もかわいそうやとか思ったりしてくる
人間守ってあげることできないでしょうに
ちょっと常識で考えてください
虫を生かしてあげるか
人間を生かしてあげるかと
虫を生かしてあげたって
虫の寿命っていうのはせいぜい 1週間程度でしょうに
それから子供を産んで
もう卵を産んで また子供を作るだけでね
そこで連続しますけど
1匹  1匹の寿命っていうのはすごい短いでしょうに
人間の寿命って何なのかと
だから生き続けて価値があるのはどちらでしょうかとか
いろいろな角度で考えられるでしょうね
だから 私も犬猫のね 体についてる虫とかは丁寧に取って丁寧に捨てますけどね
捨てたところでどうやって生活するのか
それは考えません 一応殺せません
しかし あの 自分が面倒見ている犬のこの耳にも問題が出てきて
耳に色々細菌とか色々入ったりして
虫も入ったりしてる 私は行ったら見つけたらすぐ病院に連れて
これは綺麗に洗ってくださいと
中に虫が それは私に関係じゃない
犬が大変 すごい苦しい
医者もシャーッと色々ことして
もう身を綺麗に洗って治療もして
これからこの薬入れてくださいと
薬にしても殺菌するやら
虫が残って何かでもいたら
それもなくなって それは何のことなく随分ヒッチャラで
はい 薬の時間だとか言って犬を捕まってね
大人しくしてろよとか言いながら治療するんです
だから誰かを殺す気持ちは全くないんだけど
そのやり方で死ぬ可能性はありますしね
そういうのはもう現実の世界で起こるんだから
やっぱりこの戒律とかね
罪と項目ごとにね 引っかかると邪見になっちゃうんです
ブッダが戒禁取ると これは煩悩やと
戒律やら式だりやら守るべきやと思っちゃうと
人間にどんな不幸がなるかと
それは考えないんですね
決まりだから守りますよと
2000年の伝統だから守りますよとかね
冗談じゃないんです 戒律守ることでみんなに迷惑だったら
不幸になるならば冗談じゃないんです
だからそうやって形式的な戒律やらね
この善悪の場合でも そんなに形式的に見ると頭がうかれてしまいますよ
だからそれが邪見なんです
邪道なんです それでお釈迦様はちゃんと解決しているんです
あるお坊さんがお釈迦様にもうクレーム持ってきたんです
クレームなのかというと
お釈迦様 私は真面目に修行したいと思って出家しているんだと
しかし お釈迦様が戒律は決めるは決めるは決めるは過ぎから過ぎると
私にはそんなもう 1億以上ありますよ
戒律項目は 覚えられませんよと
一つを守ろうとすると
何かまたどこかで何かを犯しているんだと
やりきれないなと これは
だからお釈迦様 残念ですけど
この戒律だけは覚えられませんし
守りきれませんし 私もダメですよと言ったら
お釈迦様何の答えたかというと
別にいいでしょう でもあんたたくさん戒律を覚えられないでしょう
では  1個だったら守れますかと
1億の代わりに 1個だったらありがたい話でしょう
じゃあ君は 1個守ってくるならば全部免除と喜んで守ります
守ります  1個なら では
心を汚せないようにしてください
それだけ  汚さないように
汚さないように それで全ての戒律を集約しちゃったんです
お釈迦様も お坊さんすごく喜んで
ありがとうございます
落ち着きました 今日から瞬間たりとも心は汚れないようにしますと
ここお坊さんだからね
心が汚れるということは
貪瞋痴で汚れないことですからね
本人がしきたり習慣でどうでもいいんです
心には欲 怒り 無知が生まれないように気をつけているんです
それで完璧に戒律を守っているんです
だから項目に引っかかってはならんです
いつでも精神的なところを見てほしいんです
だから子供が悪いことをするならば
怒鳴っても殴ってもいいんだけど
それで子供殴ってどうするのかいではなくて
あなたの心の状況は何なのかと
怒って殴ったらとんでもないことなんです
まったくもう怒ってないならば
ただのしつけでしょうに
私たちの時代では 学校では殴られますよ
先生に 全然親が文句言いません
かえって喜ぶんです ほら
てめえだらしないんだから恥ずかしいお母さんもとか
いつでも先生の味方なんです
では 正式的に殴ってもいいということになってるんだから
先生たちにとってはそれは教育の一環であって
感情の問題じゃないんです
だから先生たちも大変です
殴れるんだから殴ってやるそうじゃないんです
どの程度の悪さやったら殴るべきかと
どの程度で怒鳴るべきかと
これはシステムは自動的に決まっているんですね
時々は何か悪さやったら外へ立たせておく
立たす場もいろいろ決まってますね
ただ教室で立てという場合もあるし
あるいはもう校長室に
呼んで事務所でもみんな出入りするところなんで
そこで跪いて置いておく
これかなり大きなバスなんでみんなに見えますからね
みんなに見られるところで恥かかせてあげたりとかね
だから じゃあ教師が怒ってるかというと
全然怒ってないんですね
だから我々も子供なら知ってますよ
これぐらいのことを言ったら
教頭先生の部屋の前で膝まずくひざまずい膝かけて立ってるはなるでしょうとかね
こんなことやったら散髪はやられますよとかね
なんとなく私たちも知っている
だから手では絶対殴らないんです
すごい細いスティックを作って
あの剣とかの藤とかありますからね
細いスティックをすごい持っているんです
それはみんなに見えるところでかけてあるんです
あるいはあっちこっち見学に行く時でも
それを持って偉そうな
行くんですね この細いスティックを持って
これ振り回しながら それだけで我々は怖くなるんです
だからもう微塵も怒り感じないんですね
先生に対してもやられたっていうことで
微塵も怒りは感じませんね
ただ怖いだけで終わっちゃうんです
これはあまりにも怖い
おっかない もう言うことを聞くしかないんだぞという
だから悪さをとにかく極力やめる
どうしてもそれでもやりたい場合は
もうもっと頭使ってバレないようにやると
だからそれも教師たちだから知ってるでしょうね
だから自分にバレないようにやっちゃうと
逆に先生たちはやっぱり頭がいいんだからね
追ってくるんです 時々家から家まで見て見張る場合もあります
家ででもやってはいけないことだったら
もう家にでも来てぶん殴っちゃうということもあります
お前こんなことやったでしょとかね
向こうはあまり万引きとかしないんですけど
もし万引きなどのようなことをしたらね
学校終わってからでも
もしかすると昔の先生だったらね
聞いただけで その場で家に行くと思いますよ
家に行って出てこいと
親の前で殴って帰ると思います
なぜかというと それは教師の仕事なんです
万引きするのは社会の罪でしょ
社会に対して罪を犯したら
そこを直すのは教師の仕事です
家のことでいろいろとしたら
これは親の問題です 親は叱るべきであると
社会人としての何とかやったら
もう学校の先生の責任ということでもう
だから昔今は全然そういう体罰はないんだけど
我々の時代ではありましたしね
あってもあの細いスティックでピシッとやることだから
相当痛いし 時々ちょっと赤くなったりもするしね
それ以上何ともないんです
だから この形で決められないんです
日本の先生は殴ったらそれは悪いんで
だって感情でしょ 感情でいきなりもうもう手でぶん殴ったりするしね
これは普通犯罪でしょうし
ではなくて あなたに鞭で 3打ちますよと
を決めてちゃんと 3やると
これはもう了解の上でしょうがないんですね
だから罰を与えることが正しいということになっちゃうと
怪我させないこととかね
もう体に悪いことをしてはいけないということは当然出てくるでしょう
そういうことだから 単純に決めない方がよろしいと思います
大変です 難しいんです
だからちょこっと何とか殺生したんだから
殺生しちゃ地獄に落ちるんだ私は
とかね それは仏教とはやりません
思ってもないんじゃ悪いことしちゃった
これからやりませんよと思うだけで終わっちゃいます
嘘ついたら いや かっこ悪いことしちゃった
これから気をつけなくちゃと思うんです
だから悪人にはならないんですね
不倫も同じことでね なんでそんな不倫をして
なんだらかんだらという話はよくわかりません
これは 先生 スリランカの歴史書でマハー・マハーワンサという本がありますよね
あの中でドゥッタガマニーというドゥッタガマニーという王様が
ドゥッタガマニー 侵略者と戦って撃退した時に
どこかが阿羅漢が飛んできて
それで自分が殺生して戦争でたくさん人を殺したことについて悩んだことに対して
あなたは人は殺していないんだと
三戒も五戒もしていない
守っていない獣のような奴らを殺しただけなんだから
それを罪と思う必要はないというふうに阿羅漢が慰めたっていうような記述がありまして
マハーワンサ自体非常に神話的な内容で
いい加減な本だと思うんですけど
なんかお坊さんにそういうことを言わせるっていうのは
ちょっとなんかあまりにも脱線してるんじゃないかなと思って
ちょっと疑問に思ったんですけど
そこは私も疑問に思いますけど
で だから神話的なところもいっぱいありますけど
ちゃんと歴史的な事実もちゃんと記録はしているし
そこでマハナマ長老が書いた本だから
まぁお坊さんでしょ だから王様の話です
王様を褒め称えて書かなくちゃいけないし
ドゥッタガマニー王が本当にスリランカをね
まとめて仏教にはすごい貢献した人で
これは褒めるために ほとんどその目的で書いたぐらいの本なんですね
マハーワンサは そのためにスリランカの歴史全部書いちゃったんです
だから戦争で人を殺したことをどうするのかっていう問題がお坊さんが自分で道徳的に出てきたでしょうね
だからだらしない答えを出したでしょうね
まぁブッダゴーサ長老みたいな注釈書を書く人々はすごい気をつけますけど
まぁマハナマ長老はそこら辺でそんなに
頭が まぁ学者としていいんだけどね
仏教学の場合は で 私ならどう答えるのかというと
やっぱりあんたにそんなことを考えてる場合じゃないでしょうにと
仏教で一般人は殺されるわ
国は侵略されるわ 向こう側から来て勝手に戦争するわ
自分の仕事をしなさいよと
いう風に言うしかないでしょうに
医者の話と同じなんですね
悪人になって欲しくないんですね
人殺し屋にはなって欲しくない
戦闘でぎゃーぎゃーやってる時はもうもう敵を倒すんであって
人を殺してやるぞという事でもないでしょうしね
でも人殺しですけど だからよく私も分かりません
とにかく その時その時
なんとか人間やっちゃいますよと
日本にしたっても 誰かが来て侵略して家を焼いたり人を殺したりさんざんやっちゃうと
もう潰しちゃうでしょ
相手を捕まって  [笑い]あれやこれやと考える余裕がなくて
人間を守らなくちゃいけないということになっちゃうんですね
家族を誰かに殺されるようになっちゃうと
待っていられないでしょう
自分の仕事だから家族を守らなくちゃいけないんですね
だから相手が怪我しようが死のうがどうでもいいんでぶつかるんです
行って だから理論的にはもう人を殺したことなんですけど
罪的にはどうなるのかと
それで悪人でしたと アメリカ的にでもね
自分の家に人が入り込んじゃって
あれやこれやったところでね
もう殺しちゃっても全く何のこともなく終わりでしょうね
裁判かけませんでしょ
正当防衛ということで
だからあの罪的には何かちょっとよくわからないんですね
だから答えは心が汚れてないかでしょ
あなたの気持ちは何なのかと
どんな気持ちでやったのかと
スリランカの歴史にいたドゥッタガムニという王も
もう国民を殺される 仏教を破壊する
仏教を次から次へと破壊して寺を破壊してもう行ったという話なんですね
だから必死になって これは何とかしなくちゃっていうね
本人が仏法僧と国を守る仕事であるという
ただ必死にそれだけ で
軍隊を集めて戦っちゃったんですね
だから一般的にスリランカ人は誰も彼がドゥッタガムニ王はね
罪人はと誰でも微塵も思ってないんですね
国民をすごく自由にしてくれた王様やと
そこでさらに歴史の中での戦争でいろいろお互いに人間死ぬんだから
王様がこの相手の王がエラーラというんですけど
メッセージを送ってね
戦うことは意味がないんだと
人が死ぬんだと あなたの人も死ぬし
私たちのグループの人も死にますよと
だから敵ライバル同士
お互い様でしょうにと
王二人のためにみんな戦って
だから我々二人が戦ったらどうですかと
軍隊は置いといて行ってメッセージ送ったら
はい わかりました お前倒してやるぞと
で 決めてみんな軍隊を待っているところで
王二人が直接ぶつけたんです
で その直接対決する日を決めたところで
やっぱり心配ですね このドゥッタガムニが
誰が死ぬかわからないんだからね
もし自分が死んじゃったら
国は全体的に邪教のヒンドゥー教の国になってしまうんですね
仏教は終わり だからすごく心配して
お坊さんたちにどうしましょうと言ったら
いいよ あんたもう仏法僧を守ろうと思っているんだからね
もう大丈夫じゃないんですかと言って
いろいろいろいろお経をあげて
お経をあげた なんとか槍がありますね
人を刺す長い で その中に何かお経文句を入れてあげたんですね
じゃあこれ入れてあげますからと
あんた守られますよと
それで犯人がそれで自信を持って戦って
やっぱり自分が勝っちゃったんですね
で あの王様が槍でやられちゃったんです
槍もある仏塔を作って
そちらにも中に入れてあるんですよ
アナードプル地方には
で 亡くなった王様にはちゃんと丁寧にすごい王としてね
国葬をやって その場所も聖地に認定して
そこからは行く人は牛に馬に乗って行けませんと
降りなくちゃいけないんだと
その亡くなった王の礼をするためにとかね
そうやっていろいろストーリーがあります
今はどこに彼の遺体を埋葬したかわかりませんだけど
一応当時ではみんなこの敵王様のところを通る時は
すごいそちら頭を下げて礼をしていくように習慣まで作ってあげたという話なんですね
だからいろいろ工夫するんですよ
工夫というか ごまかしというか
よくわかりませんだけどね
だからそんな完璧には生きていられませんね
人間っていうのは だから完璧に正式的に
形的に完璧に生きようとしない方がいいんです
生き方は毎日の生き方
ボロボロでだらしなくてももうしょうがないんです
そんなのは 朝早く起きることに決めたんだぞと言ったって
朝寝坊もしちゃうしね
あんまりそういう風に厳しく自分を責める必要はないと思いますね
それだから選択の場合は
やっぱり悪人にならない方がよろしいと思いますね
悪人にはなりません とにかくどんどんどんどん心清らかにしてやるぞと
それから心守りますよと
守るのは心であって その時戦わなくちゃいけないと戦いますよ
だからといって怒りでは戦いませんよと
戦うべきところでは戦いますよ
怒りでは戦わない それなりの目的があって
やらなくちゃいけないんですね
だから心汚れないように気をつけることが
やっぱりお釈迦様のお答えなんですね
だからたまたまちょこちょこっと
やってる罪に対してはそれほど心配しなくてもよろしいんですけど
常習犯になったらダメなんですね
不倫でももうもうずっとやっちゃうと
もうもう心は汚れていますね
私も一回ぐらい不倫やったことありますよと言ったっても
別にだから何？ということに終わっちゃえばいいんです
で そっちをやってやって
またもうそこで大変なことに起きて
それはなんとかなんとか問題解決でまたやっちゃったとかね
それでまたトラブっちゃって
それでまたもうなんとかまた元に戻したところでまたやるっていう場合は
もう悪人になってますね
常習犯は良くないんですね
いうことです では  ありがとうございました
まだ若干時間ございますけど
じゃあマイクを回していただきます
先ほど長老のお話の中に
心にヒビのある人間は
いくら瞑想の窓口をしても真似事をしても
大慈禅定です 過去生でのその絵では達することができないというお言葉があったんですが
確かにお話にあるように
その私もその脳梗塞 since 以来ですね
この周りの世界といいますか
環境っていうか 外界から絶えず刺激が来て
それから心の中からも要するに万物に絶しで内からも外からもいろんな刺激が絶えず来て
それに絶えず反応しておるわけですが
それで楽しさということもあるんですが
ある時点でどうもその煩わしさっていうか
しんどいっていうか 苦しいっていうか
痛いっていうかですね
で なんとかそこをなんとかという風に思っておりましたら
以前 お釈迦様のお経の中に
そういう人間が悩み苦しみから脱出することのできる唯一の道があると
それがその大念処経っていうんですか
それでその身からず身法をですね
正知正念をもって熱烈にっていうか
こう日本の言葉ではあぶるんですかね
要するに徹底的に殺し続け
それぞれの正直は滅するところを見続けて
その世界に浸りきれば
どんな人間でもですね
早い人は七日間で 短期間ぐらいにはいけるとは書いてありましてですね
それでまあその真似事をしているんですけども
そのまあそんなこと言っちゃなんですが
残念ながらですね 所詮どころかそのサマーディっていうか
そういうようなところも自分としてはその感じたことがないんで
どうしてかなというふうに思ってたんですが
先ほどの心のヒビというような
そのあの場合の心のヒビって
なんか悪いことをしたっていうんだと思うんですが
この間もちょっと質問させていただきましたけど
どうも自分を生まれながらにしてですね
そのまああの まああのという言葉が適当か分かりませんが
その智慧がないのと もう一つは反応パターンがですね
外界からの刺激とか 心の中という反応パターンがですね
一言で言えば怒りなんです
怒りというよりんですけども
すいません 短めにお願いします
すいません で そういう人間はこの世にいるものもうダメなのかという
そういう何かあの不安があるんですけども
取りとめのない話で申し訳ありませんけども
何か解決 解決策というか
正知正念に達することはできないっていうことをもうあり得るのかなという感じがちょっとしております
お時間と申し訳ありません
あの心のヒビっていう言葉を使いましたけど
やっぱりあの生き物ですからね
だから例えば木 木も生き物でしょ
木を木の枝折れたり 頭の上から木のね
真ん中一番大事なところ
台風で折れたり折れたりしますね
すごいヒビでしょ 傷跡でしょ
しかし 生き物だからね
ある時間経つとまた芽が出てしっかり元気な木になりますね
折れた枝の傷跡はあるんだけど
別にそれどうったことなくなっちゃうでしょ
で 普通 私たちも毎日罪を犯してますよ
それなりに心清らかにしようという
頑張る 努力していくと
そんな傷跡は全部消えてどうったことはないっていうことに
まあなっていくんですね
で 例えばね あの紅茶畑でお茶畑で毎日のように葉っぱ取ってるでしょうに
それも植物の立場から言えば毎日傷跡つくんでしょ
でも別に全然大丈夫ですね
そういうことで で だから私たちの心にも毎日いろんな傷はつきますよ
つきだな 心は生き物ですからね
それなりにちょっとちょっと気をつけると
その傷跡は治します しかし
かすり傷でも今日つけて明日も午後も午前一日中体にかすり傷つくとも治る時間ないでしょう
それで化膿して病気になって感染して死ぬかもしれませんね
かすり傷であっても もうずっと体に付ける場合はもう体に対応できるスピードじゃないんですね
かすり傷なんか何のこともないでしょ
本当は かすり傷やしょ
ちょっと消毒して終わっちゃった
終わって忘れるでしょうね
次にはもう治ってますね
しかし 朝八時に仕事を始めたところで
もうかすり傷 もう八時十分でまたかすりまたと
それだったら午後に仕事終わるともう重病になってますね
重症になってるんですね
そういう法則で考えてほしいんです
そこで漁学祭っていうのは
あの擦り傷でも枝一本折れたでもなくて
やっぱり台風の攻撃があまりにも厳しくて
その木はもうダメ 復活はしないという状態なんですね
それだけはやるなよと
ただただ枝高枝一本折れたってもね
気にすんなよと ということでね
あの まあこのこの前も説明したんですけど
一番大きい私に見える問題は
なんで悩むのかいと これずっと一生悩んで悩みばっかり中心に生活することは良くないんですね
だから瞑想してもうまくいってないのは
ずっとこの悩みの土台の上でやってるんだから
土台がちょっとダメなんですね
別に悩まなくてもいいでしょうに
それから第一線上のところも何もないんだとか
なんか期待も絡んでるんですね
期待は瞑想には禁物なんですね
期待捨てて瞑想した方がいいんです
このその意味だけはちょっと説明しにくいんです
で なんで期待ダメかと
私たちは期待することが間違いなんです
そちらはもうありえないんです
真理は随分シンプルで
別な 随分シンプルなんです
このとてつもなくシンプルな真理に気づかないんですね
でっかい期待持っていると
だから四念処経はその通りに
あの固定概念がなくなったら
なんだこれかということになるぐらいシンプルなんです
これは様々な固定概念が邪魔しているんですね
固定概念も妄想なんです
だから第一線上に立ちたいなと思ってはあかん
第一線上って何ですかね
前もって知ってることだったら
もうあ これになりたいなとね
ただ店に行ったら何か面白い品物見つかる
あ これが欲しいなと思うのはいいんです
だって現実にありますからね
欲しい あ これは万円ですね
では今日は万円ないんだけど
この万円持って買いますよと
他の日で行って買えますからね
だから期待っていうのはそうやって現実的にこれということがはっきりすれば全然問題ないんです
店に行ったところで なんかすごく良さそうな時計がありましたと
あ これ これはすごいいいなと気に入っちゃったなと
やっぱり 20万円だからねとかね
でも欲しいと 夢見るのもよろしいし
どうすればあれ買えるのかと考えて
金集まったら もう集めたらもう買えるでしょうに
だから俗世間ではそういう生き方をしているんだから
瞑想にそのシステムを導入しないでください
第一戦場には入りたいとかね
思うのはいいんだけど
それは何か分かりませんよとしてください
で 一切期待しないで ブッダに説かれた通りにやってみますということだけで十分です
一言葉でも自分の思考割り込むと
かなり道が遅くなっちゃいますね
だから心の日々については
あの まあ心は毎日変化する生き物だからね
でっかい日々でない限りは
まあそのうち落ち着いていれば治ります
だから常習犯はダメと言ったんです
今日も木の枝を切って
次の日ももっと一本切って
次の日もう死にますでしょうね
木がそれだったら 枝一本切ってしまったと
まあいいや それで放っておけば一年ぐらいでまた木は元気に元に戻ります
常習犯じゃないでしょ？だからあの繰り返すやるなよとお釈迦様が言ったのはそういうことなんですね
罪を犯しても繰り返すなかれと
パーパンチェプリソカイラナタンカイラプナプナ
どうってもあんた罪を犯したというならば
二度とやる繰り返すなよと
これが困るところなんですね
ナタンカイラプナプナ
再び再びはやるなかれと
やっちゃったことはもうもういいや
もうしょうがない もう
それはもうそれなりに落ち着いていれば
もう傷痕は治ります だから日常生活でちょこちょこと悪いことしたんだからって
それは全然自分の将来のほとんど影響ないんです
あの繰り返しちゃうと
もう知ったことじゃない
またやるまたやるまたやるということになると
そういうことで 罪に対するアプローチですね
瞑想に対しても やっぱりこの
ただ単に全て無常やっていうことはわかることですよ
別にあの禅定なんか期待しないでください
あの四念処経は決して禅定を作るっていうことは書いてないんです
禅定するため作りたければ
呼吸瞑想しなくちゃいけないんですね
それだったら中部経典に呼吸瞑想も経典もありますからね
それ見ながらもうその通りにやるしかないんです
そんなにも禅定が欲しければね
禅定よりは智慧が欲しいんですね
智慧っていうのは まあ一切は無常であるっていうこと
だからサティパッタナの四念処経通りに観察してみると
もう追いつかないぐらい無常であることはもうすごい簡単に発見しますよ
追いつけない これはもういくらやっても次次次次変わってしまう
私は実況中継で教えてますけど
この実況中継できるところじゃないんですね
あんまりにも変わっちゃったりして
それでもずっとやっちゃうと
心がもう解脱境地に帰ってしまいます
はい そういう風なことで
あのもう悩むことはとんでもないんです
すごい毒ですよ 自己評価する悩みとは自己評価でしょ
自己評価 自我評価でしょ
初めからもうアウト 自我で自分を評価してダメだ俺はという
それから悩みが生まれるんだからね
そういういろいろトラブルがありますね
基本的なところ そこはちょっと直した方がいいと思います
はい  それでは時間になりましたので終了したいと思います
では回向の文で終了いたします
合掌してください  回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に礼拝帰依し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱を得られますように
Sabbe devā vimucchantu Sabba
rogo vinassatu Mā
te bhavatvantarāyo. Sukhi dīghāyuko bhava Bhavatu
sabba maṅgalaṃ Rakkhantu
sabba devatā Sabba
bud dhānu bhāvena Sabba
dhamma nu bhāvena Sabba
saṅghānu bhāvena Sadā
sotthi bhavantu te Abhivādana
sīlussa Niccaṃ
vadāpajāyino Chattāro
dhamma vadham ti Āyu
vannu sukhaṃ balaṃ Sādhu
sādhu sādhu
ではどうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございます